newly released body cam video reveals
intense moments in the hunt for a gunman
who killed nine co-workers at a
california rail yard last week
and then took his own life deputies and
police officers are seen here opening
doors to a corridor where they found the
gunman
jamie yuka shows us what happened that
day
we need access to these doors and we
just heard another fire shot down here
the santa clara county sheriff's body
cam video begins just
minutes after gunshots were first
reported and continued to
erupt at the bta railyard in san jose on
may 26th
sheriffs described the shooter samuel
cassidy as a disgruntled employee
who targeted his fellow workers officers
spoke with a supervisor
outside come back are you able to open
that door for us
give me your key cards where's your key
card at shortly after the five-member
team
enters the building a gunshot is heard
the team immediately recognizes the
situation is still dynamic
and they drive towards the area of the
gunshot two additional gunshots are
heard as they approach the exit doors
to the dispatch center
a bullet hole can be seen in the window
frame of the left door
evidence shows that one gunshot went
through the door into the direction of
the
contact team okay i got somebody down in
front of me
upon entering the dispatch center
maybe let me see your hands they found a
body slumped over a chair
the man still holding a gun in his hand
sheriff's deputies say it was the
suspect
killed by two self-inflicted gunshot
wounds for cbs this morning i'm jamie
yukis